[Música]
bueno como todos sabemos a los niños les
encanta participar en juegos que
involucren actividades creativas
construir cosas experimentar investigar
averiguar cómo funciona el mundo que los
rodea tanto es así que recuerdo alguna
vez en una actividad en la escuela
primaria cuando tenía unos seis años me
pidieron que escriba qué es lo que yo
quería hacer cuando sea grande y
recuerdo que en esta ocasión escribí que
quería ser inventor es claro cada que me
preguntaban esto yo contestaba algo
diferente pero lo que recuerdo es más
bien la motivación que me llevó a
escribir eso y ahora que me sonó a que
era algo que era como que una extensión
del juego verdad explorar cosas explorar
soluciones construir cosas
en la actualidad tengo el privilegio de
dirigir el laboratorio de investigación
en sistemas distribuidos de l'esport y
para el contexto mi charla les voy a
explicar un poquito primero qué es lo
que hacemos en el laboratorio y para
esto les quiero explicar un poquito qué
es lo que son los sistemas distribuidos
que es muy sencillo explicar son
aquellos sistemas computacionales que
tienen componentes que funcionan en
computadoras diferentes computadoras que
corren en diferentes lugares en centros
de datos o en diferentes lugares del
mundo inclusive y esto en realidad
involucra todo tipo de sistemas desde
sistemas de mensajería redes sociales
hasta aplicaciones tradicionales como
aplicaciones bancarias
y bueno en la actualidad en el
laboratorio de semestre a semestre como
participo con estudiantes los miembros
cambian pero en la actualidad tengo de
miembros dos estudiantes doctorales seis
ingenieros y cuatro estudiantes de
pregrado y estamos trabajando en
diversos proyectos de investigación que
tienen que ver con el tema de construir
una mejor infraestructura de sistemas
para lo que es sistemas de cloud
computing o computación en la nube o
sistemas de big data pero qué tipo de
soluciones o qué tipo de problemas son
los que tratamos de resolver bueno
tratamos de resolver problemas difíciles
en el área de sistemas distribuidos como
por ejemplo el de la escalabilidad la
escalabilidad es aquella capacidad de un
sistema de seguir funcionando bien aún
se aumentan la cantidad de clientes o de
usuarios de ese sistema
y aún se aumenta la cantidad de
requerimientos que recibe el sistema por
segundo por ejemplo esto es algo muy
difícil sobre todo si queremos que los
sistemas se puedan adaptar rápidamente a
cambios bruscos en popularidad en el
acceso al sistema
otro tipo de problemas difíciles que
tratamos de resolver son aquellos
problemas que tienen que ver con el
rendimiento cómo hacer que el sistema a
pesar de que sus diferentes componentes
están en diferentes ubicaciones
geográficas cómo hacer que el sistema
sea súper rápido y pueda atender una
gran cantidad de transacciones por
segundo y también otro tipo de problemas
difíciles es el tema de tolerancia a
fallos como estos diferentes componentes
son independientes es inevitable que
eventualmente fallen pero la idea es que
el sistema se pueda auto adaptar y que
el usuario final no perciba este fallo
sino que el sistema simplemente se
reconfigure
y bueno como financiamos esta
investigación la logramos financiar con
fondos de la industria hemos recibido
fondos donaciones de fondos de la
industria de google de microsoft y
también de empresas proveedoras de cloud
computing como amazon web services y
cloud lab y adicionalmente tenemos
colaboraciones activas con diversas
instituciones académicas y de la
industria también son con diversos
centros universidades y empresas
tecnológicas hacia fuera y también del
ecuador
y en todo este tiempo
además de observar obviamente además de
resolver problemas interesantes algo que
yo me he dado cuenta algo que he podido
observar es los beneficios que le traen
los estudiantes en participar en estos
proyectos de investigación
uno de estos beneficios más importantes
es la capacidad de resolver problemas
abiertos y todo esto lo clasificó dentro
de lo que podríamos llamar desarrollo de
habilidades transferibles y la capacidad
de resolver problemas abiertos es algo
que es difícil desarrollar en los
estudiantes en el aula de clases
tradicional porque debido a que uno
tiene que asignarles un proyecto que
dure un semestre
uno tiene que dimensionar bien el
proyecto y eso significa que para
dimensionarlo bien si es un proyecto de
desarrollo de software uno tiene que
pensar bien primero cómo se va a
resolver para poder saber si el
estudiante lo puede resolver en un
semestre y por lo tanto no es un
proyecto no termina siendo un proyecto
del todo abierto
en cambio los problemas de investigación
son problemas en los que no tenemos
claro cuál es la solución no tenemos
claro por qué camino está la solución y
entonces toca pensar en las diversas
alternativas de solución toca
analizarlas toca pensar cuál será la más
probable resolver el problema toca luego
implementarla experimentar evaluar y
decidir si finalmente la solución
funciona o no entonces esta es una
habilidad que los estudiantes pueden
desarrollar
y también
lógicamente en el proceso aprenden
muchas tecnologías y de hecho les cuento
una anécdota un estudiante bueno ya es
ingeniero se graduó recién en el
semestre que pasó a ser presentó su
proyecto de investigación y en la
siguiente semana ya estaba ya estaba
trabajando en una empresa y en la
empresa él analizó la arquitectura en la
nube que estaban usando y se dio cuenta
que no era la arquitectura más eficiente
para el problema que ellos tenían que
resolver y las propuestas les propuse un
diseño alterno en la empresa le
aceptaron el cambio le dijeron que lo
implemente y con ese cambio que él
propuso la empresa se iba a ahorrar unos
mil dólares al año solamente en este
pequeño componente que él propuso
cambiar pero más que nada estamos
hablando no solo del ahorro sino que de
una contribución de esa persona en su
primera semana de trabajo en la segunda
semana de trabajo el mismo
la empresa tiene clic en una empresa
pequeña desarrollo de software que tiene
clientes internacionales y querían
presentarle un análisis de datos a uno
de los clientes en una reunión que
tenían al día siguiente pero el problema
que se les presentaba es que el análisis
estaba demorando muchas horas hicieron
cálculo estimado y se iba a demorar como
unos tres días y la reunión al día
siguiente entonces él les dijo que se lo
autoriza van a resolverlo en la nube con
varias computadoras al mismo tiempo él
podía resolverlo más rápido lo
autorizaron esto les costó la empresa
menos de 20 dólares en el uso de acceso
a la nube y tuvieron los resultados en
cuatro horas y pudieron en la mañana
siguiente la reunión de las 8 de la
mañana y atender la respuesta para el
cliente
y estamos hablando en sus dos primeras
semanas de trabajo
también otra cosa que se suelen quejar a
veces las empresas es que los ingenieros
de pronto no tienen tan buenas
capacidades de comunicación y esto que
nos piden en las universidades que esto
es algo importante que los ingenieros
desarrollen mejor y el trabajar en
proyectos de investigación les permite
desarrollar esas capacidades de
comunicación les permite aprender a
transmitir correctamente sus ideas a
defenderlas no sólo transmitir la sino
defenderlas a usted ante audiencias
diversas en los proyectos en los que
trabajamos la manera que funciona un
proyecto investigación es que cuando uno
encuentra una solución algo una base
experimentos y la evalúa y después de
que la evalúa si todo funciona bien uno
documenta esa solución en un artículo
científico y este artículo científico lo
enviamos a un congreso internacional
para su revisión
si el congreso le parece bien acepta el
artículo científico para su publicación
y para su presentación e invita a uno de
los miembros del proyecto a que vaya a
presentar los resultados en el congreso
esta es una lista de las ciudades a las
que algunos estudiantes miembros de mi
laboratorio han podido viajar en los
últimos dos años a presentar resultados
de sus proyectos de investigación en
inglés ante audiencias que involucran
profesionales y académicos estudiantes
las de audiencias muy diversas y
audiencias grandes inclusive se puede
ver la foto 200 300 personas es un
tamaño común obviamente los preparamos
muy bien no porque van en representación
del lab entonces tienen que prepararse
bien les siempre les va muy bien
aprovechan a conversar con otras
personas que forman redes de contactos y
regresan energizados a seguir
colaborando en los proyectos
adicionalmente esto obviamente les
mejora todo todo su currículum y sus
capacidades de luego acceder a mejores
posibilidades una vez que se gradúan
algunos estos lo que les interesa es
hacer un posgrado y el haber participado
en estos proyectos los habilita a
aplicar y obtener ganar acceso en
posgrados muy competitivos en todo el
mundo pero no sólo eso no sólo que los
admiten sino que les son de grande la
pensión y les dan un sueldo para que
trabajen en algún proyecto de
investigación que tienen en esa
universidad con fondos de la industria
entonces estos no solamente significa la
posibilidad de ir al posgrado sino
también un costo de cero para el
estudiante y un costo de cero para el
estado ecuatoriano porque éstas no son
becas son fondos de proyectos de
investigación que tienen las
universidades con las que usan para
financiar a estos estudiantes
y bueno para la mayoría de los que yo
dirigido más de 10 años dirigido a
decenas de proyectos de investigación de
estudiantes la mayoría de opta por
quedarse en la industria una vez que se
gradúan en la industria local de
desarrollo de software pero estas
habilidades que desarrollaron como son
transferibles y son buenas importantes
para su carrera profesional los habilita
a aplicar una cantidad de trabajos más
diversos que el que podrían aplicar si
solamente se salieran con su educación
de pregrado y además en experiencia
cuando ya están buscando trabajo suelen
tener unas dos o tres ofertas para
escoger no es que tienen que pasar meses
o sea generalmente consiguen trabajo
antes de graduarse oa veces más bien
ellos les piden a la empresa por favor
déjenme terminar mi proyecto de
investigación mi proyecto de graduación
y quiero empezar a trabajar desde la
siguiente semana siempre tienes
múltiples ofertas y suele entenderlas
con mucho mejor sueldo hasta el doble de
sueldo que sus compañeros que no tienen
que no tienen esas experiencias y
claramente en dos empresas no hacen esto
porque
ellos quieran estos estudiantes que
saben hacer investigación no es eso sino
que las empresas valoran aquellas
destrezas y habilidades que los
estudiantes adquirieron en el proceso
y bueno si tuviéramos a medida que vamos
formando más gente con estas destrezas y
habilidades podemos evitar tener
problemas como los que hemos tenido por
ejemplo que si viene un artista muy
famoso como bruno mars la empresa de
venta de tickets se le cae el sistema
por cuatro o cinco horas del primer día
porque no puede manejar la carga de la
cantidad de requerimientos que necesita
manejar
o también lo que tenemos que sufrir
usualmente año a año cuando es la época
de subir las declaraciones del impuesto
a la renta como son todos los
ecuatorianos que trabajan que tienen que
hacer esto en un mes específico el
sistema se suele caer o suele estar
lento y suele presentar problemas esto
lo podemos evitar con buenas técnicas de
desarrollo de sistemas distribuidos y si
ustedes creen que tal vez de pronto
estoy exagerando un poquito les comento
estos seis ingenieros que trabajan
conmigo en realidad los fondos de
investigación me permite a mí contratar
ayudantes de investigación que son
estudiantes de pregrado o posgrado pero
si ya se gradúan yo ya no los puedo
contratar sin embargo ellos siguen
colaborando con el lab vienen a las
reuniones semanales que son los viernes
a las 8 de la mañana entonces piden
permiso en el trabajo porque hasta que
terminan la reunión y van al trabajo
llegan alrededor del mediodía y aparte
en su tiempo libre colaboran un poco con
alguno de los proyectos y esto lo hacen
claramente por los beneficios que ellos
perciben de participar en esto bueno
ellos a veces dicen que es porque les
brindo bolones durante las reuniones
pero en todo caso yo creo que es por los
beneficios que les presenta esa es una
foto justo de la reunión
la semana pasada y justo da la
casualidad que sin saber nada de la
charla terminada no fue a visitar un ex
miembro de la que se graduó como así año
y medio después del año y medio estuvo
seis meses más colaborando de congelar
ya había dejado de ir pero no fue a
contar que ya hace poco tiempo un mes
más o menos había conseguido trabajo en
una empresa de desarrollo de software
afuera y él trabaja desde aquí y es una
empresa que tiene clientes muy
reconocidos y estaban muy contentos pues
entonces como él sabe que nos reunimos
los viernes nos fue a visitar para
contar sus experiencias
y bueno lógicamente mi tema era son los
beneficios para los estudiantes eso es
lo que yo les quería transmitir porque
es lo que yo observado pero esto también
nos trae beneficios para el industrial
local les permite construir sistemas y
aplicaciones que tengan a sus clientes
más contentos y por lo tanto acaparar
más clientes y ahorrar costos a través
de buenas prácticas en el diseño de
arquitecturas de software y a través del
uso de software libre
y también estar preparados para cuando
alguna empresa ecuatoriana diseña el
próximo whatsapp o el próximo juego de
celular este súper famoso o alguna app
se vuelva súper popular poder estar
preparados a escalar a la cantidad de
requerimientos que una aplicación a
nivel mundial va a recibir por segundo
y bueno porque no tengo un futuro
también poder atraer inversión
extranjera gigantes como ibm microsoft
google etcétera invierten en centros de
investigación en países como india ghana
brasil argentina y por qué no ecuador
verdad yo pienso que esto sí es algo que
podemos conseguir pero para eso
necesitamos tener invertir más en el
capital humano del país
y bueno si les preguntan luego de que
era mi charla este título no lo puse el
inicio porque estaba demasiado largo
pero yo conseguí la charla como
contarles sobre la importancia de la
investigación de calidad en sistemas
distribuidos en la formación de capital
humano y para terminar los dejo con un
comentario del profesor de la
universidad de california en san diego
que el tuiteó que estaba escribiendo el
reporte final de un proyecto con fondos
del gobierno de eeuu de la nff y en el
formulario de red de informe del
proyecto final le pidieron a él que
escriba bueno cuáles eran los beneficios
del proyecto y entonces él hacía una
reflexión y decía bueno si generamos
software ese software está en producción
está en uso para algunas empresas
generamos publicaciones científicas lo
que significa generar conocimiento pero
yo siento es el profesor y yo siento que
el mayor aporte de estos fondos de
investigación fue la formación de estos
estudiantes que ahora que se gradúen van
a salir a hacer trabajo de excelencia
durante todas sus carreras profesionales
[Aplausos]